2672 South Deacon Street Detroit this
was the house where Rosa Parks lived
after fleeing Alabama from Michigan only
it's not in Michigan anymore it's here
in the German capital when no one in the
u.s. showed interest in keeping it
standing the city of Detroit sold it for
$500 the fact that for America this
house is of no importance the fact that
America the institutions in America
could allow this house to go on a
demolition list the fact that they sold
it for $500 the American government
thought that this house was worth $500
it speaks volumes it's actually evidence
of an enormous neglect New York native
Ryan Mendoza brought the house to Berlin
where it now stands in the district of
vetting following a long journey Rosa
Parks's nice Rhea McCauley seen here on
the Left gave the house to Mendoza as a
gift last summer he had the house
dismantled and shipped to Berlin where
it now stands on his property when
segregation laws were still in effect in
the American South Rosa Parks refused to
give a proceed on a public bus when a
white man told her to do so her act of
defiance in 1955 is widely seen as the
catalyst that sparked the u.s. civil
rights movement her role as a hero is
undisputed what's less known is what she
faced after the bus incident in 1957 she
fled Alabama with her husband after
receiving death threats they stayed with
her brother's family in Detroit 17 under
one roof
[Music]
sabia Mendoza who helped her husband
reassemble the house says the story of
Rosa Parks reflects the struggles of
many in her circumstance her family's
house in there was a situation which a
lot of African Americans live long they
came from the south
they went noise because with the hope
that they find a better life there at
that time employment that they can live
not as you see otherwise she wouldn't
have lived there with such a big family
I imagine that I mean it's a little tiny
house for so many people
the couple put up the funds to transport
the house to Berlin where they were set
on having it reassembled as an
exhibition this is something that the
Germans did they dealt with their past
and this is something that Americans
don't like to do we don't like to admit
when we do things that are wrong we
prefer our leaders prefer us to bow down
to the flag as if patriotism were the
only thing important the artists hope
that the house will eventually be
returned to the United States and stand
as a National Monument perhaps in one of
the gardens at the White House but for
now the spirit of Rosa Parks is present
in Berlin in this house where she lived
with her family